Hey what's up guys.
It's a new day and a new experiment.
Now in a previous video,
you remember we took liquid nitrogen
and put them in water bottles
and made improvised nitrogen rockets.
Apparently, some people figured out
you can do the same thing
using Coke and propane.
So that's what we're doing today.
Now in yesterday's video I showed you
how we could modify the nozzle
of one of these propane tanks
and extract liquid propane.
And we went down to the store
and picked up twelve 500ml coke bottles
so we could mix them together
and watch the reaction.
Now the funny thing about this experiment
is you don't actually have to use Coke.
I'm just throwing it in because videos
with Coke seem to get more views.
Let me explain the process
of whats about to happen.
We're going to open the valve
of this propane cylinder,
turn it upside down in a glass
and collect liquid propane.
Then we're going
to take the cap off our coke bottle
and pour out a bit
of the liquid until it's just
under the line of the label itself.
From there, it's just a matter of pouring
in a bit of liquid propane
so it sits on top,
and turning the bottle upside down.
Hahaha. You ready?
Moment of truth.
Whoops.
Fail. Look at that. [laughs]
What the heck?
That didn't work at all.
Maybe we need more propane.
Look at the top of the Coke there
when the propane hits it.
It freezes and starts gumming up.
It smells terrible.
It seems to form a layer of ice here,
so I have no idea
if this is going to work,
but the idea is that we just turn it over.
Hah! And look.
It just spills out of everywhere.
Look at that. It's just all icy,
and nothing happened at all.
Fail. what the heck. [laughs]
Ah! It's freezing my fingers.
Whoo, frosty. Yeah!
Let's see if we can make this work.
Ready?
Nothing.
I'm starting to lose confidence
that this actually works.
And those videos I saw...
I don't think they were using propane,
but they could have been using butane.
Huh.
Let's try one more time just to be sure.
If this doesn't work,
I don't know what will.
Whoo.
There you go.
Oh boy.
Haha, look at that.
Put the fire out with the coke.
I went through five bottles of propane
and a number of various experiments
and we didn't get any of them to work.
So it kind of makes me wonder
in the videos I saw,
maybe these guys were using butane
instead of propane?
Maybe that makes a difference,
I'm not sure.
But based on my experiments today,
I don't think mixing propane
and Coke has any kind of reaction at all.
The Coke just freezes,
that's really about it.
Now I don't want to let you
go home empty-handed
so for one final experiment,
we're going to try filling up
this coke bottle
with liquid propane
and screwing the cap on tight.
The question is,
is this thing going
to pressurize and explode?
Or will a Coke bottle actually be able
to contain liquid propane indefinitely?
Okay, I gotta put that down.
My fingers are freezing.
Haha, look at that.
Yeah, liquid propane can still
give you frostbite, guys.
So frosty.
So here we are, guys.
We got this bottle half full of propane.
You can see it rises above the label there.
And the thing that I noticed
right off the bat,
is how light the propane feels.
I mean, this bottle is halfway full
and it feels like there's
barely anything in it at all.
That's super surprising to me.
So let's go ahead and cap this thing off,
put it in a safe place
and see whether or not
this thing will explode.
So quick update.
I just put the cap on the bottle
and I can still squish it,
which means it's not super pressurized.
And when I shake it, it's almost
like it contracts even more,
like it squishes it even more.
Now I imagine over time,
this will warm up, it will pressurize.
In fact, we could probably
take a blowtorch to it
and warm it up a little bit quicker.
And when this thing gets to the point
where I can't push my thumb into it,
I'm just going to set it down, leave it,
and we'll see uh...
see what happens.
I'm just going to leave this right here.
Check this out, guys.
It's been about 20 minutes.
We've had this thing
sitting out long enough
that the propane has warmed up
to outside temperature here
which today is
about 45 degrees Fahrenheit.
The bottle is pressurized
but it hasn't warped and it's still
to the point where I can push my thumb in
and move the plastic a little bit.
So I don't think this is going to explode.
It seems that, theoretically, we can store
liquid propane in a Coke bottle.
Probably not the safest idea
but it looks like you actually can do it.
Okay, durability test.
And it stays intact.
That looks pretty cool.
So sweet, guys.
Looks like it's a viable idea.
A Coke bottle will hold liquid propane.
We've dropped this thing,
we've warmed it up and uh,
I think now, it's time to kill it off.
Let's see what happens
when I take the cap off.
Look, it starts bubbling.
[gas releasing rapidly]
Whoa, that's crazy.
And it started cooling down again as well.
Did you just notice that?
Alright let's light it off
and dump it out.
Whoo! Toasty.
Check it out!
Nice big ball of fire.
That's very satisfying.
Very satisfying, very cool.
Look it warped my Coke bottle.
So guys, I just turned off
our propane bottle,
so we can summarize here
for a minute what we've just learned.
We started off with a purpose to see
if mixing propane and Coke together
would make an improvised bottle rocket.
But what we found actually happens
is the propane freezes the Coke,
preventing any significant reaction
from taking place.
We tried a number of variations
of experiments
to see if we could get it to work,
but all of those attempts failed.
Oh boy.
Next, we tried filling up one
of the empty Coke bottles themselves
with liquid propane
and screwing the cap on tight
to see if we could get it to explode.
But rather than exploding
it actually warmed up
to the outside air temperature
and became a crystal-clear liquid.
Very beautiful
and apparently very stable as well.
We tried drop testing the bottle
for durability
and found that it stayed intact.
So we unscrewed the cap, lit off the gas,
and poured it on the concrete.
Well that's it for this set
of experiments, guys.
Thanks for joining me and I'll be looking
for you in the next video.
Talk to you then.
Wouldn't that be great
if it just exploded in my hand right now?